yeah leave your entry zenus already
closed welcome to the why let's wash
memes dammit this is fake right
this is CGI isn't it no piece can be
tamed my god oh my god what is this
attention Felix this is not Photoshop
okay how can I know I actually do have
69 shakers and if you let me host me
review I'll give these all the way to
fel of 19 year olds that's right we're
19 year olds right now I'm glad he's
keeping up wait I got a check 1 2 3 6 9
66 67 68 69 well done I mean technically
you're not supposed to ask but yeah ok
sure seems fair
alright I'll send you some memes I guess
[Laughter]
oh god what is this stop this so I go to
the same school as Felix did and found
him in some old yearbooks this is him in
8th grade 8 why do I still look like
child that might prepubescent memes
genes I mean whatever same thing look at
all these adults around me I look like a
woman I'm so mad how dare you how dare
you pull this on me
why am i wearing a blazer I think we
were all supposed to do it all the guys
were supposed to do it good one guys
well done I'm glad we all pulled through
god damn it
butt breath that popped collar though I
mean you know maybe if I didn't look
like I was eight when I was 13 then yeah
maybe that could have been some action
but god damn it I look so tiny he's got
a good spot he's between all the girls
player yeah that's right I definitely
was not seated in the front because I
was short that was not the case at all
ok
literally when they picked that I would
always sit down every photo I would have
to sit down so what I did ok I had this
photo I remember this
specifically because of the jacket when
we're in the group the photographer will
pick you out of the group and say like
oh you're short go front oh you're tall
go back I was like not this time mmm I
was hiding in the back this time I was
making sure I was not gonna sit for this
photo still that managed to
squeeze me and he's like wait a minute
now you go in the front
damn it and you know what my dad even
you know what he told me he said Felix
what is this photo
why are you slouching look how short you
are you're literally the shortest person
it is entire fight why do you think I
have a complex about a shot and I'm not
that short okay have you looked on
Google Google is short see I'm not that
short don't ever just can do this again
I went to the PT PI search this is my
house as a child that's funny
yes those chairs are a lot smaller than
I remember them holy grounds absolute
Madeleine what is this now my dad sent a
photo of himself with PT pi he knows I'm
a fan of Felix yeah that's definitely me
and he was so proud that he found him
even though the guy said he was lying to
be undercover and I can't stop laughing
this is very confusing no I'm a you'll
I'm a take their phone picture FBI
pretty hot too right yeah she's 14 FBI
is going to jail I knew it 10 FBI get
rip verse uno card high quality changes
fifa 2014 fifa 2019 it's funny because
it's accurate it's evolving just very
slowly same prick all over again
go freak yourself the whole sub reading
what he said that freak word I'm getting
very fed up with a lot of things this is
not good for my career but it's
inevitable
I'm basically Felix best friend okay I
don't know who that who is this guy okay
some girl some guy some guy some thing
something Conan Conan
can we point out the fact that side hoes
I forgot his name I'm so sorry also try
to do a high-five okay so there's two
versus one here basically we're in the
right Conan in the wrong Conan in the
wrong shade with me
Turner in the wrong I mean unless crash
it's really good okay so school be like
bad parents be like bad gaming be like
you are great thank you gaming this is
some Zoomer memes right here come on
guys I need to prove that you're
nineteen year old I'm fourteen this is
deep my god
thanks gamer this is so crazy wife's is
uploaded there I'll say it if it means
so much to you you're great you're great
you did it you did nothing you played
video games congratulations what do you
want a pat on the back here turn around
turn around turn around
there you go you did nothing this is a
cat he looks down on the tweet below him
it is stupid not gonna lie I would eat
baby Yoda cute cat new cart team trees
big star gets 16 million that sucks
come on team trees why don't we suck at
come on t36 it's literally suck at 60ml
this is what I was trying to explain in
my last video my big brain theory that
side cut out for whatever reason okay
it's like bulk buying right you buy one
toilet paper it's pretty expensive you
buy 20 toilet paper it's pretty cheaper
so surely maybe having 16 million
reaches 20 toilet papers do you
understand do you understand outside
thank you
so maybe we already planted 20 totally
paper when Elon Musk using my design for
his car when Elon Musk is using my
design for his new car do you guys speak
English in this channel is that what's
happening is that what is that some kind
of Pikachu hybrid I didn't think the
truck was real for the longest time and
then I realized yeah actually makes
perfect sense old trucks have if you
wash your whole conference you know the
way they talk about it
trucks have looked the same for forever
you have a company that is all male
dominant that doesn't give a if
it's an electric environmental friendly
car you have a market that it means you
have a market that you you're gonna have
to switch it off properly to do it yeah
they can make a truck
it looks cool but like everyone else but
it wouldn't do well so I think is it's a
policy move and it's a right move and I
think it's cool
I'm a joker in desmos my first post
anywhere on reddit I hope you like it
that's pretty clean I'm not gonna lie
well done I don't know what it means to
make something like this but I'm sure
it's difficult so well done hey you want
a pat on the back there you go is it a
bro face I do pat on the back snap
shout-out to all the people that just
look reddit brightly posting anything in
comments sometimes winning I do that
when there's 40 days left to plant 4.1
million trees but already cares about is
some icons disappearing oh I'm sorry I
believe I've donated have you done your
part have you done your part okay so who
actually wants a terraria series guys
okay I'll I'll think about it
opting out seriously I'll give it some
thought I'll think it $3.99 it's three
seriously 40,000 for that car it's dope
there why do I keep trying to sell the
truck to people move up a bun to right
side my thumb ain't that long boots with
galaxy fold I'm sorry is this some sort
of peasant joke that I'm too rich to
understand I didn't realize it was so
expensive that's the most privileged
thing I've ever said I didn't realize
this this very expensive product was so
expensive drawing I did of Sean Marek
Felix and Ken that's dope to the range
cool very cool this is a velociraptor
free workplace it has probably been six
days since the last incident we miss you
beat what the hell happened here I'm not
gonna lie this is either zum-zum er
boomer I don't know what it classifies
but it's kind of cringed I'm not gonna
lie I seen this and it's like oh you
ever see something that's so
in-your-face
and you kind of cringe at it but you
still feel like you need to acknowledge
it so you kind of just pretend how long
that it's funny you know what you know
what I'm tired I've sick
yeah that's this sign if someone had
this sign in front of me I'd be like oh
that's
and one of those more examples of that I
feel like there's so much humor that I
forced to go along with I think it's
time we strike back okay so many jokes
so many conversation it's like when
people talk about sport and I'm like
yeah the sports yeah of course yeah yeah
like the social norm is to go along with
it it's like that we humor what all the
humor I'll let you know if I think of it
it's coming be ready Jesus is that they
could do that posted the 69 Jesus Christ
dude
it all makes sense okay okay okay all
right all right all right all right
Jesus Christ this camera makes my
forehead a freaking huge it's got like a
how about we do this
just for head instant I like that all
right this is better my meme gets into
the why Felix da mode said I make
another one that gets into the why Felix
downloaded again alright another down
vote cool from another crybaby
I'm getting I uploaded it anonymous hero
donates 200 human kidneys that's so nice
pat on the back to ever donated 200
kidneys well done that's so nice get
this man on meme review he did have 69
but he didn't have 69 420 so I don't
know what to tell you oh that's right
you're 19 years old now congratulations
keep watching the video my 19th birthday
congratulation when the t-shirt made you
sit with the girls this punishment bro I
was not happy alright
boomers teens need to stop vaping it's
killing their lungs older boomer yeah
yeah Felix should start playing
minecraft adventure maps' herobrine's
mansion that sounds cool what is that
who's herobrine bet I can beat his ass
should I play it with friends or should
I play it alone teacher today we're
going to sweden girls oh we have Swedish
meatball boys only boys can understand
this meme if a YouTube video is flagged
as for adults then swearing should be
allowed well I'm pretty sure it is it
just means it won't get fully monetized
it's weird to me like why is there no
middle ground why can't there exist
content that are both for kids and for
adults there are so many examples of
that drinking soy
and play Nintendo switch actually I'm
fine with these things going away adults
in anime teens in anime for legal
reasons were 19 years old
[Music]
nice did you download pixel ings yes
what did it cost nothing it's free
that's a great price my god
Thank You tonneaus everywhere I go I see
his face these freakin Zoomer reddit
means I don't understand them oh my god
I have so much karma now what happened
oh of course you guys saw my account
after that yeah oh my god I got so many
offers there mods why would you remove
they gotta tell my kids this is
president of China nice well played
actually it's been proven that
vaccinated kids are more likely to have
autism because the ones that aren't
vaccinated are dead bur your child's
mental health is more important than
their grades Boomers impossible what's
up gang hey what's up gang
you are gay oh wow got him good there
that's good Jake Paul be crying again
Jay Paul crying part 2 when Felix post
LOI but you already saw all of the memes
and reddit I am four parallel universes
ahead of you Mario son damn you look
good did you work out epic this 45 year
old Indian implanted 300 acre forest how
I can do that acaba leo drat this is my
new comedy stick just being unlikable
for no reason I could probably do that
when a random number texted me and I
just play it along and Men Frick Bianca
hey could you let Bianca know I'm not
gonna be able to go to her party Friday
why not
she's in a bad mood right now I don't
think I want to tell her just tell her
dude things are kind of weird between us
right now I told her what do you tell
her so I said you weren't coming and she
said that sounds typical of you to do
just because you guys are weird right
now and immature very calmly
she said I'm weird and immature
she sold my ps4 to get her nails done
how grandparents see you when you open
their phone settings no it's also Marzia
hey it made it back bro I'm such a Elon
fanboy but like come on they tested it
they tested it behind the scenes and
look it made it fine
it's a giant metal ball okay at least it
didn't go through look at that that's
impressive
what a shame but hey maybe got people
more people talking about it now hentai
is gonna be made for kids because it's
what is going on I can't believe all
this stuff that's happening kids after
watching Nemo in 20 69 where are the
Turtles I'm gonna go ahead and say it
another controversial opinion I never
seen a turtle I don't even think they're
real Felix in 2012
Felix playing Minecraft Felix during T
Series B smash 64 I'm not falling for
this kids in 2050 oh look Forrest people
who donated to team trees we created
this they didn't exist before revs
that's right we made treats 44 days
until 2020 me thinking extreme 60 this
is so sad I'm crying and shaking I think
the weirdest part of growing up is when
you when you hear someone from the year
2000 is 19 impossible impossible where
girls crying we're boys crying we're an
army cried sayonara KSM friend money
doesn't buy up up up put Felix ending
this videos Felix and Simon stop
thumbnails now I don't want to steal
glory from side because I've already
probably doesn't get enough recognition
for all the hard work II - but I do my
thumbnails I've always done the
thumbnails every single one of them
that's right I hope this means you still
respect me or whatever respect little
respect you had is still there yes it's
funny how you little you guys understand
of the production of things whenever I
read comments are like no syv does this
and Felix just isn't like
it's not that difficult whose side
exactly sybiz crying right now
sad tree because team trees here sigh
have a pat on the back just for you
there you go because team trees is only
avoir this is so sad
just turn 30 how long do spies live
oh god I'm really proud of Billy how to
put everything in dark mode oh really
I'm really pretty yeah don't do anything
family-friendly don't do anything edgy
there's a little gray area in there
that's where you operate yeah what is it
at this point it's so weird
when pude says your pee-pee small but
Your Meme got 60 to 70 uploads small
peepee big heart small peepee big heart
you could have a big peepee heart think
about that poor Ben Affleck save energy
an artist publish work with Disney
drawings and the current world situation
some wise else's stupid s crying instead
of making ice useless as what is this
what is this can someone explain what
this is what is this
[Music]
just wait until you see their faces Oh
God
what is the head skin looks like Chinese
bootlegs of the actual characters
minecraft community cave update please
frozen you said frozen right you want
frozen here you go here we go we supply
you want frozen do you want it frozen
right you want snowy or snow that's what
you want right
frozen that's right yes it is out wait
what is this minecraft marketplace what
it's out I am what is this oh so you can
download Oh Norse mythology mashup
that's cool why have I not downloaded
that what there's a ton of cool start
what is all this what that's so cool I
think this is only if you have the
Microsoft version though it's not the
Yama version is it yeah I'm not gonna
get the full Microsoft version you
working from Anka Oh Tecna you came for
Anka Oh three o'clock today to change
air watch behind you what normal people
see what gamers see for I've con EA West
came out of that car I would have
literally be like that's breathtaking I
was at I lost my breath if nobody's born
cool except of course there is one
person in the u.s. name born cool Wow
is that true bright if it wasn't for
Marcia I would name my child some some
meme name like dick who names their
child dick that's beautiful
you need a child that shapes their you
need a strong name write something that
will make them bully people we say oh
you shouldn't make you shouldn't give
them bad names because they'll get
bullied they need to get bullied you
don't know just I mean I understand I'm
making a weird case here but the point
is yeah you can give your child a
trivial name like I don't want to call
you guys out but like a common name like
I don't know Eric
Hanna and they'll just glide through
society and everything was fine or you
could give them a bully worthy name like
penis dick that's names that's gonna get
you somewhere you're gonna be the most
resilient person on the planet
thanks to me because I'm your daddy and
I name you a horrible name you're
welcome child yeah time goes so fast it
feels like yesterday we were 9 years old
my god
what's up 19 year olds smash like on
this video I have to speak like you guys
are teenagers now now that's it Mojang
ads honey block mumbo-jumbo reality can
be whatever I want
oh my god who wants mr. B's to rent a
private island and play real-life
minecraft yes school bands bags sir boy
turns up carrying books in microwave
last week my meme got 2000 up coach it
may get into the wife kids just uploaded
he saw your meme and said you have
someone big P P whoever made this yeah
we're gonna sue his ass selling this
account full access 10 euro why are you
playin fortnight because I need 10 euro
more to buy minecraft I am homeschooled
I really want my crap damn I feel this
brother not funny
extant and that's funny first guild a
meme dies reddit there is another no one
heals himself by winning another it's a
Shannon it is beautiful
she's a great attacker I almost beat
their Floatopia I'm on the last level
gamers
no one cares Felix oh sorry morgues is
cancelled number one trending for gamer
YouTube we have advanced algorithms that
can detect what your video is about also
YouTube we're gonna use advanced machine
learning to understand it's fine we can
trust it it's okay I'm gonna tell my
kids this is PewDiePie element Gloria
Borger
excuse me glorious more eager show some
goddamn respect for glorious Marga
I never tried to direct my content to
kids nine year olds hold on this whole
operation was you it's true that I've
been criticized so much for like I don't
tell the kids to watch me old times were
better old times from reddit all times
were at all times already okay rah rah
rah blah blah blah we are the best I
want
what time there was there were people
like we're living the time like what the
1960s 40s everyone keeps referencing the
80s hey Felix we're still waiting for a
closet review 2019 it's almost end of
the year okay okay I will I will
Wow another cool one damn let's say
watch me I love it so cool everyone
keeps painting me with white hair do I
have to diet again or some
I seen I literally saw this before so
funny to t-rexes fighting over a
circular saw one image can change so
much depending on your beliefs
I believe in t-rex wait a minute this
whole operation was you alright alright
gamers that's it for this week's Wow
I love that recording these well done on
all the memes smash like and subscribe
if you enjoyed and check out what
Deborah Fudd we're all excited about the
new game that's coming out and I can't
wait to play it it starts with the
letter P can you guess what it is
here the pie pick sailing of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you